يبدو الأمر أشبه بمشهد من
طيور هيتشكوك ثم واحدة من
أكثر الساحات ازدحامًا في اسطنبول عادة ما تكون
مليئة بالأتراك والسياح على حد سواء ولكن ما
هو طبيعي هذه الأيام بعد الآن على أي حال
تركيا تراهن بشكل كبير على أن
إجراءات فيروس كورونا ستكون
رهانًا ناجحًا لتطبيق حظر التجول  فقط
في عطلات نهاية الأسبوع و 31 مقاطعة
وإغلاق ينطبق على أولئك الذين
تقل أعمارهم عن 20 عامًا أو أكثر من 65 عامًا لتخفيف العبء
عن أولئك الذين لا يُسمح لهم بالخروج ،
توجد مراكز اتصال في كل منطقة حيث
يمكنك فعل أي شيء بدءًا من طلبات البقالة التي
تطلب الصيدلية  حتى الحصول على
راتبك التقاعدي الشهري ، والداي من
كبار السن ، ويعيشان في مدينة أخرى ،
هناك شخص ما يفعل ذلك من أجلهم.
يتم إغلاق جميع الأماكن العامة جنبًا إلى جنب مع معظم
الشركات الصغيرة ، ويقيم العديد من الأشخاص في
المنازل ، لكن الإجراءات المعمول بها
خلال الأسبوع ليست شديدة مثل  إنهم
في بلدان أخرى ، إنها إستراتيجية محفوفة بالمخاطر ،
تحتل تركيا المرتبة الأولى عالمياً في المراكز العشرة الأولى عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالحالات المؤكدة لمرض كوفاش 19 ،
حيث يزيد معدل الوفيات عن 2 في
المائة ، وهو أمر يعزو وزير الصحة
إلى العلاج الذي
تستخدمه تركيا لعقار الملاريا
هيدروكسي كلوروكوين.  و favi bravia أحد
مضادات الفيروسات اليابانية في وقت مبكر جدًا في
بداية kovat 19 أخبر الأمة
وتأخير التنبيب باستخدام
الأكسجين عالي التردد لفترة أطول
من الوقت
وتصر الحكومة على أن تركيا ليس لديها
مشكلة في السعة ولديها الكثير من الأمور
الشخصية  معدات الحماية
تقوم المدارس المهنية التابعة لوزارة التعليم
بإنتاج أقنعة للوجه بدلات الجسم بالكامل
وأردية جراحية من صنع المعلمين والطلاب
جالونات تم إنتاج المطهرات في
مدارس أخرى تحولت إلى أقنعة بطاريات مؤقتة صغيرة ،
وهي الآن إلزامية
للجميع لارتدائها ولكن يمكنك في الواقع '
لا تشتريها حتى من الصيدلية التي
تتقدم بها عبر الإنترنت وكل أسبوع يحصل كل شخص
على 5  أقنعة لكبار السن الذين لا
يُسمح لهم بالخروج ، تم تسليمهم رأوا أن
الخروج في السبعينيات من عمرها يعيشون بمفردهم
وتزوج أطفالها ، لقد مر شهرين أو ثلاثة
أشهر منذ أن فقدت عائلتها ،
وسألنا عما إذا كانوا في اسطنبول ،
نعم هم تستجيب  وهذا
يجعل الأمر أكثر صعوبة.
أروى ديمون. CNN قوية